chaville sèvres joinville montmartre les
connaisseurs reconnaîtront les noms de
petits vins l'âge pour la production de
prestige il faut se rendre près de la
ferté sous jouarre où les vendanges du
champagne ont commencé trois communes
sont classées défaite défendu
gaillardement par une poignée
d'irréductibles khogyani jandilla dans
la sphère qui dira jamais la longue
peine des confréries vineuses qui d'un
bout à l'autre de l'année arpente les
terres à vignes d'île de france hélas
pour beaucoup abandonnés
la dernière née des confréries
coulommiers a mené son inspection
générale annuelle avec tout ce que cela
implique d'exigence intérieur est
sérieusement la réalité physique de la
région veut que trois communes
produisent vraiment un champagne sur des
surfaces limitées certes mais pour une
qualité vraiment authentique
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour un 10 ont une
bonne terme champagne c'est un sol
crayeux parce que la craie si vous
voulez avec la réverbération du soleil
vous renvoient les rayons du soleil et
c'est ça qui fait mourir le raisin en
même temps que l'histoire de la
photosynthèse donc des feuilles problème
de clorinde assimilation de chlorophylle
chlorophylle et qui fait mourir le
raisin en champagne géographique les
grands crus non plus de terres à
cultiver et veulent s'étendre les petits
vignerons ont donc à résoudre des
problèmes de spéculation s'ils veulent
subsister plus les aléas des conditions
atmosphériques
il s'est mis à faire froid au moment de
la floraison au mois de juin
et ça nous a fait ils vont disparaître
une bonne partie de la récolte suivant
les parcelles
ça va 2
devin prendre pour cent voire même
jusqu'à 50% est-ce que ce qu'il a fait
très froid la nuit
il pleuvait dans la journée sans avoir
des grosses primes et yb roussinet il ya
de l'humidité dans le feuillage froid la
nuit
ce qui fait qu'au niveau de la
fécondation l'a perdu énormément de
poids à cette période et la qualité du
produit sera bonne quand la qualité sera
bonne
au delà du folklore même sympathique
donc il y a une possibilité de
développer une vie pour le fruit ou le
20 mai à regarder certaines images on
voit où vont les préférences de certains
amateurs sont elles décembre